- On this episode, I talk about
micromanaging versus delegating, and
monitoring my employees'
behavior on social.
(upbeat music)
You ask questions.
And, I answer them.
This is
The #AskGaryVee Show.
Hey everybody, this is
Gary Vay-ner-chuk.
And, this is episode 176
of the #AskGaryVee Show.
We're back on our home turf.
I feel like that rented stadium over there
changed up our vibe.
The saltiness, the weirdness.
By the way,
let me start with this.
And, let's get on with the show.
Actually, we were shooting the shit.
But wait, I've gotten dick pics already.
By the way, it's super shocking.
(laughing)
Even though I have one and whatever.
You know what's funny?
It's not shocking as a whole.
Like, if I looked it up,
I wouldn't be shocked.
It's just that you don't expect like...
Yeah, you don't know what's coming.
(laughing)
- [India] The surprise factor
is probably the worst part about it.
- [Man] Oh, and see your face
like when it comes through.
(laughing)
- I think we used up all our time.
So, I told them we'll do one question.
But, I'm already feeling it.
So, maybe we'll do a couple more.
And, I'm gonna go a little faster.
But, for everybody who watches
or listens this in two speed,
this is about to feel maybe four speed.
Can I just say "thank you" to everybody?
Like for a second?
The amount of you in DailyVee,
and then the couple of salty episodes
the last two days.
The amount of you like "Gary,
"I see something terrible
is going on in your life
"through your eyes."
Or like "Gary, don't worry.
"I know the pressure in the world."
Not the same old characters
that are always bantering with me.
Like, a lot of people have emailed me,
DM'd me or snapped me
in the last 40 hours,
checking in on me, which is so...
I'm so thankful.
It makes me happy too.
Because, it also, you know.
My mom has said this
to me for a long time.
She calls me sunshine.
And, she says that because she says that
I elevate everybody's mood.
Like, when they're around me.
And, it was really interesting.
I really felt it from the community
that because I wasn't
at my 100 like "Yeah!",
like people felt it.
And, they're like "Wait a minute.
"Hey Gary, this is what I signed up for."
Like, people are really like "Hey man,
"I know your spiel at this point.
"I signed up for 20 minutes because
"I want to get jazzed and feel good."
And, I'm like "dammit".
Like, it's really fast.
And, I push against this.
I don't want to be positivity,
and motivation and energy.
I also want to be tactical,
and operational, and put
myself out of business,
if you hadn't read that article.
You know, and so, thank you.
Because, that it super flattering.
And, I do think selfish
to a couple of you.
So, I will bring your levels up right now.
India.
So, India.
Let's
get into--
- The show.
- No no, stick with me.
Do this for me. Ready?
- Yes.
- The show!
Great.
Thank you, India.
- [Woman] Brock.
- Brock Lesnar?
- [Woman] No, Brock from the Waldo Group.
- Ok, Brock.
- [India] He snapped it
to you, and screenshot it.
I don't know if you saw it--
- Amazing. Go ahead.
So, is it going to show
up as a snapped screen?
Oh, like that?
Got it. Awesome.
- [Woman] You talk about the importance of
building one to one relationships
with your social media.
- By the way, let's do that.
Guys, one of the things that is
not scalable right now,
or I haven't found the
app yet and I'm busy.
I want to throw more snaps.
Obviously, I'm all in on Snapchat.
Don't know if you heard.
You can download your
video from your story,
and probably from your
one on one interaction.
I just haven't done that.
I don't know. Can you?
If you send somebody a
message in video form,
can you download that?
To your phone?
Alright, maybe you can.
Or, actually, you know what?
Even better.
You know what?
Actually, you know what?
(censored) it. I'm going in.
You know what? I'm changing.
I'm flipping the switch here.
I'm going in for a right hook.
Already, people are emailing me that
a lot of value has been provided to them
on the Snapchat strategy, and
good things have happened.
I want you to do the following.
I want to do a series of shows like this.
But, this is my right hook.
I want you to add the #AskGaryVee Show
@garyvee's handle.
Follow him on Snapchat.
Like, ask me a question for the show
in your Snapchat story.
And then, tell people to follow me
@garyvee on Snapchat.
Because, I appreciate it.
I want to build up my follower.
I'm going in for a right hook.
But then, download that.
Because, you put it on your story.
So, all your people are gonna see it.
But then, download it.
And, submit those questions.
Put it on your Twitter.
I don't want to do email.
So, put it somewhere where we can see it.
So, I think email,
or Instagram, right.
They can download it.
That's what I do.
DRock, thoughts?
- Length.
I know it's length.
You're always worried about like.
Who cares if it looks that way?
You do.
Anyway.
So, let's get some Snapchat questions
on that way.
I would probably tweet
@India that you're doing it.
This way, I don't want to double game it,
and get your Twitter exposure too.
I don't want you to.
The story's more than enough.
@India.
Let's put up India's handle here
for the few that don't know.
And, embed your question
on Twitter from Snapchat.
And, let's get a bunch
of Snapchat questions
in video form.
It's your chance to get
your face in front of
tens and tens and tens
of thousands of people.
Hundreds.
- [India] Ready?
- Yep.
- [India] Alright, Brock.
- Brock Lesnar.
- [Voiceover] Brock says:
"You talk about the importance of building
"one to one relationships
through your social media
"and that you should do the same
"for your customers and employees.
"Do you follow many of your
employees and like/comment
"on their personal content?
"Traditional management would
say no go, what say ye?"
- I follow.
- [India] And comment?
- Yeah.
(unintelligible)
Yeah, I mean I engage.
I'm always laughing when employees.
We're closer.
We get to spend more time.
But, there are employees, you can imagine,
that maybe I don't get
to see for four months.
And then, I'll show up on
their Instagram and say
"Yeah".
And, it's like a picture of
like her and her boyfriend.
And, she is like "This is the
creepiest shit of all time".
Look, I'm not following any company rules.
Because, I'm not scared of being sued.
Because I truly believe in my life
that intent trumps everything.
Like, you could sue on anything.
You know, like anything and any time.
You can make up anything.
And so, the answer is...
How'd it go again?
Like "how thy see say"?
What is that?
No no, the end, when he
said "how does thee say?"
What is it?
- [India] "What say ye?"
- Ye says
that I watch a lot of the content
everyone's putting out here.
Remember I made a reference like
"Oh, India's putting up like"--
- [India] I had no idea
what we were talking about.
- Ok.
But it was like you put
up like a nice picture.
Yeah, but something like,
you were like...
Anyway.
Nonetheless, I'm seeing
what everybody's doing.
And, there's a lot to see.
And, there's funny stuff.
But, don't forget it's public domain.
Right?
On Instagram, they have to accept me
if they want to follow me.
I don't feel like I'm intruding,
because it's the rules of the game.
I'm watching because I
want to know them better.
My intent is to follow so I
can make it better for them.
Not so like "Oh, Staphon, you're fired.
"You drink beer too late at night."
Intent.
Intent
is what trumps everything.
And then, I engage,
because I'm coming from a good place.
And, they get pumped.
A lot of employees are
happy when I engage.
Because, they think it's cool.
And they're like
"Look how weird my boss is."
You know what I mean?
So, I just think intent.
So, yes I follow.
Yes, I engage.
I don't engage a lot.
Because I do have respect for like
everybody views these things differently.
So, I'm trying to be smart.
I don't want to make
anybody uncomfortable.
But, my intent is pure as (censored).
You know, like I want it to be good.
I'm doing it for good.
And so, I'm not scared like
executives in companies.
Companies are bad often.
They don't care about their employees.
So, their intent is bad.
"Hey, we need to cut 50
people from payroll this year.
"Let's follow people on
social and blame them."
That's what happens.
Guys, what do you think is going on?
That's what's going on.
Not everywhere.
Intent.
- [India] So, it shouldn't
be a surveillance tool
for your company.
- You can do anything you want.
Like, you know companies
that are highly regulated;
Pharma, Financial.
They're scared of the
government suing them.
So, they're not mad at the employees.
They're just doing governance,
so that they don't become
exposed as a company.
So, I understand why they have that.
Intent.
If you are a financial service,
and you're monitoring your people,
and you're not letting
them be on social media,
because the government makes you feel
that you'll be fined for doing something,
that's not intent that's bad.
They're just protective.
Got it?
Don't look at the tactics.
Trail it back to the intent.
Right?
"Gary Vee, VaynerMedia's awesome.
"They can do anything."
Ok.
But, your place might not be not awesome.
It might be more vulnerable to things.
Maybe your CEO is also scared
of those kinds of things.
Maybe if I got massively
burnt one day in my career,
I'd take a step back and change.
Intent.
Always changing.
- [India] From Stephen.
- Stephen.
- [Voiceover] Stephen asks:
"Gary, are you more of a
delegator or micromanager?
"Can't wait for the UK book tour!"
- Both.
I delegate everything that I think is
not the single most important
things in the world.
And then, I micromanage the things that
I think are the most
important things in the world.
Luckily for me, hence
why I've been able to
build big companies.
I don't think most things matter.
So, I don't think I'm any
different than anybody else.
I actually think that
everybody is a delegator
and a micromanager.
I just think my radar of
what's important is different.
Yes, we need to do something with that.
That's the shit guys.
That's it right there.
I'm just like you.
We're all the same.
We all delegate.
We all micromanage.
The difference is
I don't think most things matter.
And, what do I mean by that,
as I'm trying to think about somebody
watching this for the first time,
instead of alluding to people
that have watched forever.
Most things don't matter.
That's what it means.
If I was like, I don't know.
I don't think lighting matters
as much as DRock.
I just don't think things matter.
I don't think like one
client that's going to
put us out of business.
I don't think one employee's
gonna kill our atmosphere.
I don't think a lot of things matter.
I don't think like a misspelling
in a deck is something
that really matters to a
lot of people in my company.
It just doesn't matter to me.
I just don't think so.
Guys.
Guys,
I don't think we're going
to lose the account,
because we put the I before the E.
And, if we do, (censored) them.
Idiots.
I don't think not wearing
shoes in an establishment
is the biggest thing in the world.
Clearly, if you've watched DailyVee 1,
some people do.
And, guess what.
I do not judge.
Do not judge.
Everybody's allowed to do their thing.
It's just like parenting.
I will never spew my parenting.
I talk about it.
But, it's very holistic.
Like, this is what I do,
not what I'm telling you to do.
This is me.
But (censored) like.
So ultimately, I think that I'm both.
Like everybody in the world,
I just think that I deem
what's most important
at a very very high level.
You know what? A lot of you
are commenting about
my five minute meetings.
Most of you, because you're
part of my community,
think it's great.
A lot of comments on YouTube and Facebook.
Like "Ooh, I like DailyVee because
"Gary spends five.", that's nice.
One comment.
By the way, whoever said this is going to
see this and be like "Holy
crap, he reads everything."
"I've worked at small companies where
"the boss didn't even know my name."
You know what I mean?
Like this is cool.
But, do you know how many people
think it's stupid?
I have a lot of people
in my life that think
that I'm very busy, and I
have a lot of things to do.
And, why in the world?
Gary it's not scalable.
It's not sustainable.
Yeah, you're making that face,
because you're so in our cocoon.
Just like, you know.
Don't do that.
It's not bad.
Nobody expects you to do it.
Not at this scale.
And, you have a great culture.
And, you have great intent.
Just do that.
I'm like "nope".
This thing matters to me.
So micromanaging a hello
into my company three to six months in,
that a lot of people outsource to
an HR person or to leadership.
So, I do unscalable things all the time;
micromanaging if I deem
them the most important.
Pitching new business.
I like to micromanage that.
Because, it's important to win business.
Money helps me keep doing everything.
Cool.
- [India] From Corey.
- I really should go.
I'm being a jerk.
Question of the day:
What is the thing that
you most micromanage,
because you believe
it's the most important
thing that you're doing
in your world today?
Love you guys.
You keep asking questions.
I'll keep answering them.
(hip hop beat)